this thing you had with Thurman Munson
you guys are teammates and yet you're at
each other's throats Thurman Munson was
a great guy good family man and Thurman
Munson told George go signed a big guy
in Oakland and so he was part of the
reason I came here as part of me coming
here getting a raise George was supposed
to add to Thurman's money
and take him to the same level you know
and Thurman and I had a meeting and I
told him what I was making George didn't
make the move
Thurman got upset so that was part of it
then I got Lippy uh made a comment
um that they turned into this straw that
stirs the drink something was attributed
to me that I did not say that Thurman
could only stir it badly right and you
never said that absolutely not because a
guy kept saying they had lost four in a
row to Cincinnati and he said uh Reggie
now so what's your role here and I said
well you know I don't I think I'm the
last piece I'm the final ingredient he
said so you were like the straw that
stirs a drink and I said yeah okay if
you want to save starless there's a
drink fine and when I said they got it
they got attributed to you that you said
I stirred the drink well and Thurman
doesn't that's right so did you ever go
to Thurman Munson and say yes I love you
uh you you helped me get on the Yankees
yes and what happened yes uh George
wanted a meeting and that meeting took
place in the sauna in New York in a
sauna the meeting yeah in a sauna and
then we also met in in a club in Detroit
but we made our peace then the article
came out
oh no yes and that destroyed the
relationship and I said I was misquoted
and Thurman said it's 3 000 [__]
words
you were misquoted I mean so and uh from
there it was just like a cold war for a
while until really we got together and I
made a few trips with him on his
airplane and you know oh no kidding yes
yeah he flew and you were on the plane
yeah yeah we patched up our differences
and uh got back together and you know
got together
foreign